scp-682 vs scp-743  could the world's most terrifying  chocolate fountain filled with an  endless supply of omnivorous insects  finally be the thing to fell the  hard-to-destroy reptile initially there  seemed to be hope exactly as the  foundation intended 682 consumed some of  the delicious chocolate marking it for  death by the nightmarish creatures  lurking within the swarm soon burst from  the fountain and began attacking and  devouring scp-682  the creatures consumed 21 percent of  682's mass before the monster finally  fought back it evolved a long  anteater-like tongue that it used to  catch and eat many of the insects the  insects and 682 fed off of each other  for days and after the two were  separated having consumed 743's  chocolate appeared to have temporarily  given 682 heightened regenerative  abilities after observing this the  researchers concluded that the two  anomalies should never be brought into  contact again